just an
uh out there question i remember i think
i think andre capati had a blog post
about computer vision
uh like being really hard i forgot what
the title was but it's many many years
ago
and they had i think president obama
stepping on a scale and there was humor
and there's a bunch of people laughing
and whatever
and uh the interesting there's a lot of
interesting things about that image and
i think andre highlighted
a bunch of things about the image that
us humans are able to immediately
understand
like the idea i think of gravity and
that you can you have the concept of a
weight
you have a you immediately project uh
because of our knowledge of pose
and how human bodies are constructed you
understand
how the forces are being applied with
the human body they're really
interesting other thing that you're able
to understand there's multiple people
looking at each other in the image
you're able to have a mental model of
what the people are thinking about
you're able to infer like
oh this person is probably thinks like
is laughing
at how humorous the situation is and
this person is confused about what the
situation is because they're looking
this way
we're able to infer all of that so
that's human vision
how difficult is computer vision
like in order to achieve that level of
understanding
and maybe how big of a part does
self-supervised
learning play in that do you think and
do you still you know
back that was like over a decade ago i
think andre and i think a lot of people
agreed because
computer vision is really hard do you
still think computer vision is really
hard
i think it is yes and getting to that
kind of understanding i mean it's really
out there
so if you ask me to solve just that
particular problem i can do it the
supervised learning route
i can always construct a data set and
basically predict oh is there humor in
this or not
and of course i can do it actually
that's a good question do you think you
can
okay okay do you think you can do human
supervised
annotation of humor to some extent yes
i'm sure it'll work i mean it won't be
it won't be as bad as like randomly
guessing i'm sure it can still predict
whether it's humorous or not in some way
yeah maybe like reddit upvotes is the
signal i don't know
i mean it won't do a great job but it'll
do something it may actually be like it
may find certain things which are not
humorous humorous as well which
is going to be bad for us but i mean
it'll do a
it won't be random yeah kind of like my
sense of humor
okay so if i'm so you can that
particular problem yes but the general
problem you're saying is hard
the general problem is art and i mean
self-supervised learning is not the
answer to everything of course it's not
i think
if you have machines that are going to
communicate with humans at the end of it
you want to understand what the
algorithm is doing right you want it to
be able to
like produce an output that you can
decipher that you can understand or it's
actually useful for something else
which again is a human so at some point
in this sort of entire loop
a human steps in and now this human
needs to understand
what's going on so and at that point
this entire notion of language or
semantics really comes in
if the machine just spits out something
and if we can't understand it then it's
not really
that useful for us so self-supervisoring
is probably going to be useful for a lot
of the things before that part
before the machine really needs to
communicate a particular kind of output
with a human
because i mean otherwise how is it going
to do that without language
or some kind of communication but you're
saying that it's possible to build a big
base of understanding or whatever
of um concepts
yeah the common sense concepts
you